تابعوا معنا التفاصيل اذا مشاهدينا الكرام
الانتشار انتشار مراسلي الجزيره اعطانا
صوره تقريبيه كيف تسير المعارك على الارض
ويبدو ان المعارك الان تتركز على المنطقه
الجنوبيه من العاصمه الخرطوم هذه مدينه
مروي طبيعه بطبيعه الحال اصبحت يعني
مشهوره للغايه هذه المدينه التي كانت
شراره هذه العمليه العسكريه التي بدات قبل
خمسه ايام من الان ولكن المنطقه الجنوبيه
من العاصمه الخرطوم هي الان التي تشهد
العمليات هذه الخرطوم التي تلتقي على
النهرين الازرق على النيلين الازرق
والابيض وعند عند ملتقاهما يتشكل نهر
النيل المنطقه الجنوبيه للخرطوم هي التي
تتركز فيها المعارك اذا ما اقتربنا اكثر
هذه هي الخرطوم التي تتكون من ثلاث مناطق
الخرطوم الرئيسيه التي تقع في المنطقه
الجنوبيه الخرطوم بحري التي تقع في
المنطقه الشماليه الش
واندرمان هذه الثلاث مناطق هي التي تشكل
مدينه الخرطوم الكبرى العاصمه العمليات
العسكريه الان تتركز في المنطقه الجنوبيه
وتحديدا عند هذه المسافه التي تربط بين
النيلين كما ذكرنا الازرق والابيض في
المنطقه الجنوبيه حوالي عشره كيلو متر هذه
المسافه التي نتحدث عنها وهذه المسافه
تتشكل من ثلاث احياء رئيسيه هما حي
الصحافات وهو مجموعه احياء تشكل حي
الصحافه او احياء الصحافات في المنطقه
الجنوبيه وحي الجبره في هذه المنطقه ايضا
هناك جبره شمال وجبره جنوب واحياء المدينه
الرياضيه او هي عباره عن اسواق واماكن
تجاريه وملاعب ومدينه رياضيه كبيره تمتد
من النيل الازرق الى منطقه الصحاففات
العمليات العسكريه الان تتركز بشكل اساسي
في هذه المنطقه تحاول القوات الضغط بهذه
المواقع لضرب
اكبر عدد ممكن من معسكرات الدعم السريع
التي تتمركز في هذه المنطقه في حي المدينه
الرياضيه والذي كان شراره او كان له تركيز
كبير خلال الساعات القليله الماضيه هناك
مركز عمليات او معسكر مهم لقوات الدعم
السريع في المدينه الرياضيه لذلك يركز
الجيش هنا تصريحات الجيش عن انه عن بدات
عمليات التمشيط ويبدو ان عمليات التمشيط
للجيش بدات بالفعل من المنطقه الجنوبيه مع
الحديث الذي ذكره هيثم قبل قليل بان
العمليات العسكريه تقريبا شبه متوقفه في
المنطقه الشماليه للمنطقه الجنوبيه
والخرطومه نتحدث عن يعني جنوبي النيل
مباشره هذا المربع الذي يضم القياده
العامه ويضم المطار كما نلاحظ ويضم ايضا
القصر الجمهوري هذه المواقع الثلاث يبدو
ان العمليات العسكريه فيها توقفت الان وفق
ما
وصلنا من معلومات وفق ما اتحدث هيثم انه
لم يلاحظ اي عمليات عسكريه كما نلاحظ على
الشاشه في هذه المنطقه ويبدو ان الامور
هادئه في المنطقه الشماليه او محيط القصر
الجمهوري ومحيط المطار ومحيط المقر
القياده العامه لتتركز العمليات العسكريه
في المنطقه الجنوبيه وتحديدا ايضا على
شارع الستين هذا شارع الستين الذي يمتد من
هذه المنطقه الرئيسيه بجوار المطار الى
المنطقه الجنوبيه والذي يتقاطع ايضا مع
شارع اخر هو شارع مدني والذي تتحدث عنه
هيثم ايضا قبل قليل وهذا الشارع اهميته
بانه يربط الخرطوم بالولايات الجنوبيه
والباقير التي تتحدث عن هيثم والتي كما
نلاحظ على الشاشه في هذه الخريطه هذا هو
الشارع الذي نتحدث عنه شارع مدني الذي
يربط الخرطوم بالمناطق الجنوبيه او
الولايات الجنوبيه التي قد تشكل الان
عمليات دعم وامداد للطرفين
للجيش للدعم السريع الذي يحاول الضغط على
الخرطوم من عده محاور يبدو الان ان خطوط
الامداد تتركز بشكل اساسي من المنطقه
الجنوبيه ومن المنطقه الجنوبيه الشرقيه
بدرجه اساسيه لتكون كما ذكرنا هذه المنطقه
المدينه الرياضيه والصحافات وجبرا هي الخط
الذي يمتد الى عشر كيلو متر بين النيلين
وهي خط الجبهه الرئيسي مع تصريحات الجيش
بانهم ينفذ عمليه تمشيط ومسح للاحياء طبعا
هذه كثافه سكانيه عاليه هذه الذي تمتد بين
النيلين هذه المنطقه كثافه سكانيه عاليه
وايضا مساحات واسعه للزراعه وهي اكثر
المناطق خصوبه للزراعه في السودان
وبالتالي تكتظ بالسكان وبالتالي سقط عدد
كبير من القتله قبل قليل ايضا شاهدنا صور
لاحد قيادات الجيش لا اعلم من هو يتجول في
ام درمان وام درمان اهميتها كما ذكرنا في
اكثر من مناسبه انها تحتوي على المقر
التلفزيون وهي طبعا مساحه واسعه من
مشكل اساسي للعاصمه الخرطوم الخرطوم
الكبرى ام درمان وتحتوي على مقره تلفزيون
لذلك تولي لها القوات العسكريه التي تريد
ان تتقاتل تولي لام درمان اهميه بالغه هذا
هو المشهد حتى هذه اللحظه معك كما ذكرنا
خلو العمليات العسكريه وفق ما ذكر هيثم في
هذه المساحه التي تمتد الى عده كيلومترات
من هذا هو المطار اذا كنا ربطنا الصورتين
ببعضظهما
المطار وهنا مركز القياده العامه على هذه
الصوره نشاهد المشهد هذا هو المطار وهنا
القياده العامه على الخريطه هذه الاكثر
قربا نشاهد حتى الان يمكن القول بان هذه
المنطقه الاكثر هدوءا بعد ايام من الصراع
والقتال العنيفه التي شهدته هذه المنطقه
مع الحديث عن اغلاق هذه الجسور بطبيعه
الحال في الايام القليله الماضيه قطع
الجسور التي تربط بين خرطوم بحري وخرطوم
والخرطوم الجنوبي او منطقه المطار ومنطقه
القصر الجمهوري والقياده العامه التي تكون
هذه المنطقه كما ذكرنا منطقه هادئه وهذه
المنطقه الان المنطقه الجنوبيه هي المنطقه
الاكثر اشتعالا بالقتال المستمر في اول
ايام عيد الفطر السعيد